[Music]
a cacophony of car horns as
demonstrators opposing covid19
restrictions converge on the most famous
street in paris
[Music]
this inspired by hornblaring freedom
convoy demonstrations elsewhere
spot the canadian flag
[Music]
it's been two years and we know we're
fed up now
the people are suffering and we don't
understand anything there are laws but
we don't understand them
all i've understood is that we're now in
a nazi dictatorship honestly
paris is no stranger to scenes like this
demonstrations are frequent and
passionate
[Applause]
[Music]
no stranger also to the liberal use of
tear gas by french police
on the edge of paris hundreds of
vehicles were stopped before they could
enter the city with on-the-spot fines
handed out in abundance
the pandemic seen european governments
exert power over people's private lives
like never before
most eu countries including france are
beginning to gradually ease restrictions
mask wearing in most indoor settings
will be lifted later this month
but a vaccine passed to enter public
places will remain in force until
hospitals are able to function normally
a campaign by president emmanuel macron
against anti-vaxxers has the backing of
most french people but the government's
demands are too much of an intrusion
into the liberties these demonstrators
are out to defend
[Music]
leave parker al jazeera